in the words of the wise sage in poet
Kanye West the system broken in fact so
broken that you can now steal your very
own election the first way to steal an
election gerrymander what does that even
mean gerrymandering is when the lines of
a voting district are redrawn so that a
certain political party can have an
advantage in winning an election and
that means more seats for that
particular party in most states this
process is controlled by the majority
party in the state legislature take
pennsylvania for example in 2010 the
gop-controlled legislature redrew the
congressional district map in their
favor and that meant that when the 2012
midterm elections came around despite
only getting forty-nine percent of the
popular vote Republicans walked away
with seventy-two percent of
Pennsylvania's congressional seats yeah
that's legal still not convinced well
you can also steal an election by
changing state laws in order to make it
harder for voters who oppose you to even
get to the polls yeah the 1965 Voting
Rights Act was a groundbreaking piece of
legislation and in 2013 a Supreme Court
decision basically nullified a big part
of it thanks to scotus nine states
mostly in the south we're given the
right to make minor changes to their
voting laws without getting federal
approval what have those minor changes
look like asking for photo ID at the
polls initiatives to fight voter fraud
usually led by Republicans have resulted
in over a dozen states adopting strict
and non strict photo ID laws but there's
not that much evidence to support the
idea that voter fraud is an epidemic let
alone a problem what is clear though is
that these laws are keeping people away
from the polls people who are young
people who are black people who are poor
now what would the GOP want to keep them
from the polls if changing district
lines or keeping people disenfranchised
doesn't work you can always exercise
your right to free speech
in 2010 the Supreme Court voted to
recognize independent expenditures for
political campaigns as free speech what
does that all even mean an independent
expenditure as free speech means that
super PACs can spend an unlimited amount
of money on campaigns and candidates
they want to support but that's meant
the rise of dark money which is when big
donors donate to nonprofit groups who
don't have to disclose where the cash is
coming from in 2012 alone these
nonprofits spent more than 250 million
dollars on campaigns and so far this
election cycle more than 700 million
dollars has been spent through
independent expenditures that's a tall
skinny vanilla latte from Starbucks
every day of the year for more than five
hundred and fifteen thousand years so
with a system so broken how is it anyone
going to fix it